si la reserva federal se mantiene fiel
en su estrategia de endurecer las
condiciones monetarias en este país y
frenar la inflación de ahí esa subida de
los tipos de interés de 0 75 puntos una
subida agresiva que no casa para nada
con la política que hemos visto de la
fed en los tres últimas décadas en las
que esos aumentos o subidas eran tan
sólo de un 0.25 por ciento conduciendo
la economía a un ritmo mucho más lento
es la cuarta subida en lo que va de año
la segunda consecutiva algo histórico lo
que hace dar una idea lo que da una idea
de lo decididos que están a frenar esta
inflación esto qué significa significa
que los préstamos para coches para
vivienda para tarjetas de crédito van a
ser mucho más caros esto hará que los
consumidores pues gasten menos y esto se
espera que frene la inflación justo
después de la reunión ante el comité de
la reserva federal en un comunicado han
anunciado que están dispuestos que el
objetivo es que esa inflación se reduzca
hasta un 2% están dispuestos a seguir
subiendo los tipos de interés recordemos
que ahora mismo la inflación aquí en
eeuu está en un 86 por ciento